five years after the cdc initiated a
crackdown on opioid pain medications
experts have concluded the policy has
really been a miserable failure overdose
deaths have gone up not down and now
courts are starting to recognize the
arguments used to justify the crackdown
are really largely bogus the i-team's
george knapp has the latest
these numbers they just
push these false numbers and and now
you have
courts of law
calling them out
las vegas physician dan laird has a
unique vantage point from which to
evaluate the great opioid crackdown he's
not only a pain management doctor but is
also an attorney who's represented
patients who suffered after being denied
legal medications of the 50 million
americans plagued by chronic pain about
20 million depend on prescription
opioids to try and lead somewhat normal
lives since 2016 those millions have
suffered immensely because of a war on
legal pain meds chronic pain patients
are basically in a fight for their lives
they've been under attack for several
years now with this
anti-opioid sentiment and sort of the
overreaction to the opioid crisis
laird says the campaign against opioids
is largely about money more than 1500
civil lawsuits have been filed against
drug companies by state and local
governments including in nevada as
officials and trial lawyers eye
multi-billion dollar settlements but the
lawsuits most of which accuse big pharma
of being a public nuisance for causing
the opioid epidemic are starting to fall
apart in california this month a lower
court tossed out a huge lawsuit with a
scathing opinion that found the
underlying facts don't support the
allegation that 25 percent of opioid
patients get addicted and in oklahoma
the state supreme court reached a
similar conclusion and held the benefits
of opioid meds far outweigh the risks
but the litigation narrative the the
narrative that
the trial lawyers
want to push is that it's prescribed
opioids that are causing all of these
deaths but prescription drugs are not
the cause of a spike in overdose deaths
90 000 ods were recorded in 2020 a huge
increase but 87 percent of those were
caused by illegal street drugs notably
fentanyl and heroin not prescription
medication cutting down on prescriptions
hasn't worked because legal pain
patients are not the ones overdosing
studies show less than one percent of
them become addicted not 25 percent as
alleged in the lawsuits millions of
patients who followed the rules and
their doctors have been cut off
altogether or had their dosages slashed
suicides among those patients jumped 470
percent many of them veterans in pain
were cut off by the ba patients are
starting to fight back by suing doctors
and hospitals who deny legitimate
medications also coming under scrutiny
are the very same anti-opioid crusaders
who crafted the cdc's opioid crackdown
in 2016. several are now working as
expert witnesses in the lawsuits against
big pharma one person andrew kolodny who
is a psychiatrist with no formal
postgraduate training and pain
management
is an expert witness for
again oklahoma case against johnson and
johnson pharmaceuticals his expert
witness fee for that case
reportedly is 500 000
so it's pretty good work if you can get
it george knapp 8 news now
now in the developments the u.s supreme
court agreed a few days ago to hear
arguments related to the prosecution of
doctors who have been found guilty of
criminal charges for prescribing legal
medications did